the views and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program and do not
necessarily reflect the views and
opinions of 8 news now or next our media
group
we actually believe
from our internal polling that this is a
dead heat race it's going to be a sprint
through the finish line
tonight on politics now hustling towards
the primary election republican senate
candidate sam brown says he's gaining
ground on front-runner adam laxalt
we should reinstate this all women's ban
joe biden calls on congress to pass gun
control legislation we dig into how
bipartisan talks in congress are going
and safeguarding our schools new
technology ccsd is trying to protect
students and staff
[Music]
from eight news now this is politics now
thank you very much for joining us here
on politics now i'm john langler and we
start with the upcoming primary election
one week of early voting is now in the
books so far nearly 24 thousand people
in clark county have voted the most
popular locations at the galleria mall
and centennial center nevada is a closed
primary state so we can't read too much
into the number from each party that
have voted already but early voting does
last until june 10th and you can vote at
any of the early voting locations all
the details are at eight newsnow dot com
nevada's senate race it's the most
watched one in the country the
republican primary it is getting closer
as we approach primary day wounded
veteran sam brown says his polling has
it as a dead heat i spoke with him about
the race the country issues in the
country and his opponent adam laxalt
let's start with an issue that certainly
the entire country is watching now in
light of what took place in texas
last week this horrible shooting at this
elementary school it gets the idea of
gun rights legislation is being
discussed some of it anyway on capitol
hill if you're elected senator what kind
of legislation would you support to
potentially
alter
gun legislation gun rights in the u.s
yeah so i think the the root issue here
is
uh that we have a mental health crisis
in our country and
um you know in in the case that uh of
this texas shooting it's obviously a
tragedy
um families are burying their loved ones
as we speak and in an open investigation
so you know i think there's a lot to be
learned about this case but
we need to look not at how do we erode
the second amendment and people's
ability to lawfully own guns but how do
we help parents in many cases identify
when their child is struggling with
mental illness and
we do need to do a better job of making
sure that those resources are available
to everyone
and that's something that has been in
decline here in the united states is
access to mental health resources is the
focus gun ownership or is the focus on
the kinds of guns we're talking about
here assault weapons versus
something that is used for sporting or
something along those lines yeah
the the sad reality is that if someone
is at a place where they intend to do
mass harm
to other human beings
they're they're going to find a tool or
a weapon to do that and so i think that
to
to
to isolate it on one type of weapon
is is the wrong approach and will
continue to be
you know saddened by tragedies with
other you know weapons being used as
senator would you do or would you change
anything about what's what is uh in law
in nevada with regards to abortion and
broadly about funding for planned
parenthood
so so you know i'm pro-life um
but it's uh it's not necessarily
constitutionally protected here in the
state it's uh
it's nrs um but like as a senator i
on a federal level i have no control
over what the state uh does but
look if if the people of nevada want to
bring that issue back up and put it back
on the ballot that's something that the
people will have to do
but i am not
in support of any federal funding for
abortion whatsoever so you would if you
were elected to the senate you would
vote against it you would
find ways to yeah in fact i think look
to be pro-life shouldn't just be to
protect life in a womb it should be to
to protect life even after
birth when there are challenging
circumstances and so i you know i think
that we need to look at how do we help
you know fund and lower the cost of
adoption how do we ensure that when when
a woman feels like
her choice is either to not be able to
afford to provide for a child or to
terminate that life that we ensure that
that you know
funding to you know for diapers or
formula or you know just the basic
necessities of raising an infant uh that
sort of support is there and that's the
sort of federal funding i think that we
could look at one is with inflation
we've seen the effects on wall street
the effects on main street everything
costs more there's a little bit of a
difference between you yourself and mr
laxat with regards to how quickly
lawmakers on capitol hill should act and
how quickly the fed should act what do
you believe is the best option for
uh trying to deal with inflation and
trying to cut down the cost of of life
yeah so
two things will help this um and and it
there's not going to be
a really quick turnaround here but the
quickest way to get to it is
lower energy cost as fast as possible we
need to do everything we can to get back
to american energy independence the
lower the energy cost the
the better our economy will work and
will help bring down prices but federal
spending is another tool when congress
is is spending you know trillions of
dollars at a time
you know just recently uh 40 billion
dollars to ukraine that they don't even
necessarily know where that money is
going to come from
look they did that in nine days
they can't even pass you know relief uh
emergency funding you know post
hurricane or you know after a wildfire
in nine days so congress has got to stop
spending so much and we also need the
fed to stop printing as much money did
you know that about 80 percent of the us
dollars in circulation today were
printed in the last two years we see the
the lower levels at lake mead i mean
there's intake uh
pipes that are now showing and other
things are showing as well
what as a senator would you do to try
and
improve the situation on the colorado
with regards to water resources working
not just in nevada but with other states
nearby
to try and make sure we don't run dry
yeah
california has got to manage its
resources better
they recently had a 15 or 20 year long
process of permitting for a new
desalination plant which is supposed to
help provide some relief
for us off the colorado
they got you know basically to the
finish line to say oh we're not going to
do that
look california has water access that we
do not have and so if if they're not
going to better manage their resources
then it may be the case the federal
government needs to step in and and
force uh california to do that so that
we can have a larger allocation because
this 100 year old agreement of where
the water allocation goes is is outdated
and doesn't reflect the current
population there's a couple of weeks
left in the republican primary season
what do you plan to do to try and bridge
that gap
yeah so
i'm behind in about three week old data
now
we actually believe
from our internal polling that this is a
dead heat race it's going to be a sprint
through the finish line
we've closed a gap of about six weeks
ago we were down 37 a little over a
month ago we're down 22. three weeks ago
we were down 15. there's a trend that we
are we're closing the gap our internal
polling is showing that we're going to
continue to to make phone calls have
volunteers in the field i'm all over the
state
and we've got momentum and we're going
to win should point out we did invite
adam laxall to the chief opponent for mr
brown on this week as well he canceled
his scheduled interview you can watch
discussions with both candidates we have
had before on 8newsnow.com the winner of
that republican primary faces incumbent
senator catherine cortez masto in the
general election this week she held an
asian-american pacific islander event
this is video that was provided by her
campaign the senator touted her small
business loans working on that during
the pandemic and setting up a federal
hate crime reporting system
our primary is underway as you know
early voting has started here's a look
at the latest civics poll it has
president joe biden
pretty far under underwater here in
nevada overall he has a 34 percent
approval rating 55 percent disapprove of
his work among independents it's even
worse in nevada just 22 percent approve
of the president's performance
republicans have been steadily eating up
some of the democrats voter registration
advantage here in nevada democrats had a
more than 97 000 voter advantage back in
2016. in 2020 it was about 87 000 today
it is just under 59 thousand
nonpartisans have also increased by 95
000 since 2020
after a school year dotted with violent
incidents on campus clark county school
district is trying to make schools safer
and this week it unveiled a pilot
emergency alert system it's from a
company called syntegics each staff
member can wear a lanyard with a card
and a button on that card staff can
click on the button to initiate a staff
alert for example if there's a fight in
a classroom
right now this is going to be tested at
nine schools when school gets back in
session but it can also initiate a
campus-wide emergency lockdown if an
intruder enters the building at any time
superintendent dr jesus jar would not
say how much this system would cost
it's reallocating of dollars
this is a priority
our children and our staff need to be
safe we are prioritizing our existing
dollars
to make sure that our staff is safe
another pilot program is being
introduced at el dorado high school that
is audio based of course el dorado is
where a teacher was
assaulted at near the end of the school
year
school safety is a nationwide issue
after last week's shooting at an
elementary school in texas next on
politics now we'll talk about the deals
democrats and republicans are trying to
reach on capitol hill
plus we talk with the coach who is
challenging ccsd trustee danielle ford's
seat on the school board
pacific southwest emmy awards
welcome back to politics now
nevada is pulling its investments in
companies that make or sell assault
style weapons this week state treasurer
zac conan announced the move in reaction
to the recent mass shootings we've seen
across the country so this pullback
amounts to 89 million dollars nevada's
total investment portfolio is about 49
billion dollars konin says his office
will make sure the investments won't be
sold for a loss or cost the state any
money
conan is right now up for re-election
one of his republican opponents is las
vegas city councilwoman michelle fiore
she is as you can see a strong supporter
of first amendment rights the other
republican running is manny kess either
one would be able to overturn the
internal policy that mr konin referenced
if they are elected to that position
in a prime time speech on thursday night
president joe biden renewed his call for
new gun control measures among the
policies he wants universal background
checks bans on high-capacity magazines
renewing the 1994 assault weapons ban
and ending the immunity that protects
that protects gun makers from liability
the president also made an emotional
plea after several recent mass shootings
how much more carnage are we willing to
accept
how many more innocent american lives
must be taken before we say enough
enough
joining us to talk about the continuing
negotiations between republicans and
democrats alex limon from our washington
d.c bureau alex this week the house
judiciary committee took up and debated
a package on gun measures what is the
likely outcome of that legislation
that's right democrats are actually
trying to be pretty ambitious in the
house that package is a really wide
sweeping package of gun reform bills
that includes at least eight different
bills so far
um and they include measures like
raising the minimum age to buy
a semi-automatic rifle from 18 years old
to 21 years old also a measure in there
that would ban high-capacity magazine
clips and those are two two of the bills
that democrats are choosing to highlight
because they say they play such a big
role high-capacity magazines and
semi-automatic weapons
rifles
in mass shootings that's what's
happening in the house let's talk about
what's happening in the senate
negotiations in that evenly split body
they're still continuing what's the
latest in the senate
so we actually have heard from some of
the senators involved in those
negotiations senator chris murphy and
richard blumenthal of connecticut as you
know they're the two senators that
represent the state where the sandy hook
shooting happened
and so they have been very key and
central to these negotiations and they
actually say that
they are encouraged a bit by the way
these negotiations are happening they
said that there are more republicans
involved in these talks than ever before
they say the talks are happening
vigorously on a daily basis even though
the senators are back home in their home
states they are
talking whether it be by phone or
discussing things virtually so they are
encouraged by the fact that these talks
are even happening because you know time
and time again we've seen very quickly
after tragedies and mass shootings uh
negotiations just fall apart and things
go nowhere and so these senators
say they hope that this time will be
different that they can find some common
ground but we've also heard from
republicans although i will say neither
party is giving us a lot of details
about what specific measures they're
discussing or any other specifics of
that nature but they both say they are
talking
and that was alex limon from washington
d.c nevada requires background checks on
private party sales and we already have
a red flag law that allows a court to
confiscate a weapon
the race for the clark county school
board next on politics now jay calhoun
joins us he is running for the school
board why he would vote to fire the
superintendent if he's elected and why
he's in favor of prayer in schools plus
interior secretary deb holland
quarantined in las vegas her visit to
the valley and her coveted diagnosis
this is how we show our community
you're watching politics now
some students who were victims of
for-profit colleges are having their
student loans forgiven that includes
those who went to everest college in
henderson it closed after findings of
fraud were uncovered the bide
administration is also eyeing a more
widespread student loan relief package
for americans who are facing mountains
of debt the white house is reportedly
working on a plan to cancel ten thousand
dollars in student loans per borrower
we're continuing our coverage of the
race for the clark county school
district board danielle ford is up for
re-election for her district fc a lot of
people are running for that seat as well
one of her many challengers is jay
calhoun he works for ccsd in tech
support he also coaches sports i spoke
with him about his goals for the
district
talk about your background for those who
don't know
with clark county school district and
why you've taken the the
leap into running for the school board
awesome so
i worked in clark county school district
actually starting as a bus driver so i
was a bus driver with clark county
school district because i wanted to help
with coaching at desert oasis and i was
suggested to get into ccsd to become a
bus driver because there was a deficit
of bus drivers so i made sure to come
over
then i coached with desert oasis
going on three seasons
about an end season and then two full
seasons and then going after that i
moved over to rancho high school and i
was the site-based tech i've been in i.t
for going over about 12 years and
i became the
head soccer coach there rancho high
school so it was i love being involved
with the kids especially because i have
three kids and they're all in ccsd so i
wanted to make sure that i could be
present i could be that active dad you
know i feel like a lot of times people
see the moms being active but dads have
voices too what will your experience
potentially bring to the school board
that isn't there right now
accountability
focusing on one thing one thing i've
been saying this whole campaign ccsd has
adhd
they they do not focus on one problem
they go to so many issues but then
there's so many things that's in the
background that's crumbling because they
haven't focused on an issue and actually
solved it
speaking of security speaking of teacher
retention speaking of actually giving
raises so that employees don't leave so
that we can have schools that can
actually stay open so that in the fall
we can actually know that there's
accountability there's staff there's
resources and when it comes down to
resources
every parent asked i think for years why
after all of the tax money that comes in
why is the teacher still short resourced
and don't have the actual resource they
need in classrooms why do parents have
to come together and rally in it's like
having a gofundme for supplies that
should be
given to our children the woman whose
seat you're trying to take voted and has
been very outspoken about trying to get
dr jar out of his position
would you
vote to fire or terminate his contract
if you're elected absolutely because one
thing i believe is
performance he he has every teacher have
a performance eval he has every person
under him as administrator that's why
all the administrators are in a rat race
to get on top and make more salary
because of this eval the testing based
off schools but no one actually
evaluates the superintendent no one
actually
checks him in that well no they do that
every year there's an evaluation for the
superintendent all the administrators
it's in their school board meetings uh
at least once a year
and where has it been shown
if you've seen the performance of jarrah
the main thing is he wants to bring in
teachers last time he put the initiative
to bring in all the teachers when we had
a deficit from the philippines now he's
trying to bring in more teachers by
raising the salary to 50 000. so
where's the actual change how does your
faith guide your uh candidacy and your
desire to be on the school board and
maybe some of the changes you might like
to see implemented
across the district well my faith
obviously i'm a christian and i i
believe that
i've been praying for the school
district because i know a lot on my
twitter i've been doing prayers
when the shutdown was happening when
last day of school when all these things
were happening
and prayer needs to be back in school i
remember we had a moment of silence and
everybody could be able to do a prayer
or whatever you wanted to do but
a time to be able to get a relief
away from all of the hectic things in
this world this world has gone crazy
since covet and everyone's trying to get
back to the norm but we have to kind of
figure out what that is
the idea of prayer in school is
obviously somewhat controversial there's
i think a supreme court ruling that's
expected soon on a case out of
washington state on that you're
suggesting that you would like to see
prayer
in public schools i would love to see
prayer in public schools
you can see more of our interview with
jay calhoun with danielle ford who
currently has that seat irene bustamante
adams is also running for the school
board that's all there at
eightnewsnow.com
two byte administration cabinet members
were in las vegas this week
transportation secretary pete
butterjudge was at a ground breaking for
the i-15 and tropicana big construction
project there that project would include
replacing tropicana with a new bridge
over the freeway and upgrading the
flyover as well the exit there it's
about 50 million dollars of the 305
million dollar price tag is coming from
a federal grant
interior secretary deb holland was also
in town this week but her stay was a
little longer than expected she tested
positive for coronavirus wednesday and
has had to isolate here tuesday she was
promoting clean energy policies with
senator catherine cortez masto
more
[Music]
this weekend what to watch we're keeping
an eye on the last week of early voting
for the primary if trends keep up with
past years close to two-thirds of the
votes in the primary could be early or
by mail
plus the u.s supreme court will release
some decisions on monday they haven't
said which ones yet but in particular
we're waiting to see if the much
anticipated ruling on the future of roe
v wade could come from the supreme court
on monday we will certainly keep an eye
on that we thank you so much for
watching us here on politics now all the
political news you need is at
eightnewsnow.com we're back with you on
saturday we thank you so much for
joining us take care
[Music]
you